[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits
I'm Linc and I'm Rhett it's time for
another candid conversation with someone
interesting from the internet this week
on the roundtable of dim lighting well
not on it just around it we have glozell
green vlogger extraordinaire
self-proclaimed queen of the Internet
that's what it says in our YouTube
channel I'm not I'm not gonna deny it
she's Queen Lee she's got she's got
millions of views 400 million views that
might make you queen of the Internet
yeah I'll take that she's gonna talk
about growing up as the only black
person in an all-white school how she
got banned from the Tonight Show and the
fact that she accidentally accidentally
made a video that now has over 20
million views is called my push-up bra
will help me get my man and I say I'm
very envious of her because she's gonna
tell you the story of what I mean by
accidentally made a viral video and when
she told that story I thought to myself
really really you didn't even intend
this thing to be a viral video now it
has more views than anything we have
ever made and we've been sitting here
for six years trying to so how are you
make viral videos we try very hard we
always have try very hard I'm not gonna
you know we're not gonna lie to you
about every video that we know this is
the one this was really gonna do it and
you know we've been fortunate enough to
create videos that have gotten millions
of you some really quickly other ones
have really surprised us but which ones
are surprises I think once you say that
I kind of need this I I was specifically
thinking of the chiropractor commercial
well yeah that one as big as it did as
quickly as it did
but I mean it's maybe I just said well
it's a different thing
we're not vloggers we don't we we could
never create the video that she created
that none of yous ever with it but it
fascinated me that it was a very
different approach and a different
strategy but has become you know what it
is today the glozell green
that you're going to meet and going to
enjoy another story that she's gonna
share with all of us is how she met
Elijah Wood in a Quiznos and what
there's a the bathroom is involved
that's all I'm gonna tell you and then
the the what happened there ends up
translating into a story that Elijah
Wood talks about on Jimmy Kimmel it's
just crazy how she just kind of find
yourself in these situations sometimes
making videos that just change the
course of her life I love that about her
story but the other thing it made me
think of was an encounter that my wife
had with a famous person in a public
restroom all right I've told you this
before now Katie Holmes before she was
in Batman and before she married and
divorced Tom Cruise she was what was
that show she was in Dawson's Carlson's
Creek filmed in Wilmington North
Carolina
yep and Dawson's Creek was kind of
winding up I uh I think you wind down
why can't you getting ready to start
winding down is this about the end thank
you for catching that Yeah right because
it I want to be clear that it's when
Dawson's Creek was winding down yeah
yeah there's a way with friends it was
over she was her career was winding up
is what I was thinking okay yeah but for
some reason she was back in Wilmington
and my wife Kristy was also in
Wilmington at a seafood restaurant yeah
what is next to the beach lots of
seafood restaurants and I think there
was a buzz around the restaurant I was
not there so this is second-hand
knowledge to me that there was a buzz
around the restaurant Katie Holmes is
dining in this seafood restaurant and
the flounder Christy saw her dining
there and then she's have two eyes on
one side of her head and then she's
leaving you do you really want to talk
about that right now I'm just filling in
get the guess you just you're just
pepper eating this story with flounder
facts no thanks
like a salt and peppered flounder
Christie has to go to the restroom after
they after she's eaten you know she's
about to pay
she had the flounder - you have to get
up and pay at this place it's one of
those fish camp type places in
Wilmington uh-huh she goes to the
bathroom
someone's in the bathroom wonder who it
is doors locked
she's waiting there awhile take a little
Dawson's peek it's a great story I've
heard it before this I'm trying to
entertain myself and then finally
finally the door opens after what seemed
like hours it was just minutes probably
and lo and behold you know who it is
miss Katie Holmes comes out and she's
her eyes meet Christie's as Christie's
about to go in the restroom one person
at a time type deal obviously and Katie
says to Christie I I wouldn't go in
there the that's it's out of order
oh the bathrooms out of order hmm you
know what that means
and then Christie says well I got I
gotta go I gotta give it I gotta give a
shot I gotta go in there anyway she goes
in there and it's it's like clogged up
big time Katie clogged Katie dropped a
big old bomb little girl big bomb man
she felt right at home she threw she did
not want anyone to go in there no I mean
it could have been on the tabloids but
my wife was gracious she only told me
the story and then many years later am i
disseminating it through an iTunes yes
in the past now but yes I mean she lied
and tried to cover it up she just say
I'm I blew it up in there you can't do
that when you're a celebrity you can't
do that you can't you can't admit I was
just washing my hands in there and here
we are with bathroom humor again but the
crazy thing about glozell story with
Elijah Woods is is it's wood there's no
s it's not plural there's what is it's a
bit it's kind of the opposite but it's
equally it's
equally impressive and crazy of a story
and she's got an equally impressive
career thus far with 2.2 million
subscribers on the YouTube and over 400
million views on her Chan the internet
cinnamon challenge video alone has over
33 million views and she's got quite the
interesting story and here it is our
conversation with glozell green are you
taking a picture of your all honey
now glozell I noticed that you have your
pocketbook still around yes show her I
don't owe you people's and I'm from
Florida and y'all will get away with
doing whatever y'all want to to me I
already know that so I have to be
prepared to run cuz it's just us and
there's dim lighting minutes you know I
you know but do Manolis worthy not at
all noel look he looks shady not only
trustworthy a little but that's the ones
you got to watch can you got that
sweater you know like it's a beautiful
day in a neighborhood it's like I don't
know so you have issues with Mister
Rogers he was from Florida so I do like
him however there was some mystery about
him I don't know he played with trains
and little kids I don't know now you
just said it's not gonna go that you
have never tried coffee never I've never
tried coffee alcohol or any kind of
drugs or smoking man well huh no you did
I just thought i just threw coffee and
without garland drugs i mean i
understand these are the things I
haven't tried coffee a gateway drug for
you uh you know what it could be I won't
know cuz I haven't tried it so why I
mean I got some right here at least got
some right there well anyone no no I'm
like well see now that I'm over 40
what's the point now it's just the
novelty of staying in the watch people
go why so now it's fun I won't try
because people just like home but
Starbucks well they have to yell oh look
at you look very perplexed like so yeah
I'm serious
you do i do duty because i I do like the
British and I like pretending
I really do I put on the Hat and this is
my name is Cecily Cardew I have a really
great time by myself nobody else is
there I have this coffee right here this
could be the opportunity hello no okay
don't even try it now you said me how
people want to press you into do you
know the drug send me a coffee I'm just
throwing that out there
oh we know about cinnamon oh 33 million
views later but no you said we that you
you don't know us but I I'm trying to
tell you that we've met on multiple
occasions maybe twice did you have the
beard Oh y'all wait still we yep I was
white and I've had this beard for quite
some time
okay I haven't shaved and I haven't
shaved the bottom part of the beard in
over a decade
it was after the streamys after the
streaming's our wives want your picture
taken with you bet you I remember two
wives what did they have on good they
looked great it was toward the end it
was after the stream more like over to
your side uh-huh
yeah everyone when you were in the
parking lot afterwards I'm like you were
almost totally away no because I took a
picture with this girl from the middle
do you remember that uh-huh I don't
remember the picture on another middle
though the girl no the middle
she was the show yeah the show she was
there and I took a picture and then I
you guys came up after that so I do
remember that's right
yes see I remember cuz I didn't have
coffee and prior to that we had a text
exchange because I got ahold of your
cellular telephone number and I started
texting you and trying to tell you who I
was because I wanted you be a super note
captain mm-hmm
do you remember this and yeah I was like
I would not have been here yeah I was
like I like and you were like I don't
know who you are I know you guys are
very famous popular yeah you know I
remember that I am now making the
connection to the two things okay but
you were you were pretty busy I mean
you're a busy lady this was a very big
go out the country or something right at
that time right remember that and plus
you don't understand when I do videos I
don't add it on to do anything so when
people ask me to do stuff that requires
effort really like even driving I'm like
okay if it was a foot per car what
Cooper car like it just wouldn't but I
driving in videos no you see me behind a
wheel in video Oh filming yourself car
moves that's what I just bought a car
but I don't I don't now you recently got
married like I'm talking weeks ago
almost two months so I want to get to
that but we would pray for huh we
usually like to kind of go back to the
start but I will say congratulations
thank you go back to the start of what
the first minute of your life I mean
first memory my first memory I actually
removed being born okay I get when I say
that see this is why I'm using that what
people cuz that sounded strange but I
remember going like late but mom says I
remember like a dream about it but I
remember I feel you were probably just
what looking at photos and then there's
no photos of me being born they didn't
do that kind of photo though that's like
yeah cuz I'm um you said you were over
40 yeah I know black don't crack but
it's starting to gear so I might get a
little Botox attack see just a little
bit on this side cuz the saddest
drooping just a little bit late right
now it's on this that make it even you
see it's even now if you get a lot of
that it'll just make you look surprised
constantly that's all right
that's pretty good I do that all the
time anyway oh yeah okay so you remember
emerging I do I do being blonde don't
believe that for the red no one does
what's the next memory I remember there
was this what what state are we in we're
in Florida okay where all the loony
people come from we are we're orlando i
was born raised in orlando florida
mm-hmm and i was fun fact that was
breastfed till I was four so you do
remember that yeah because I was on one
side of my sister who's three and a half
years apart from my side no I had to be
around four there you go so you were
competing with your sister I won -
there's not
really a competition uh well I want that
one you meaning you took both breasts no
because I was breastfed the longest go
mom was like forget this after you know
like to who and I was who entered that
you are your mom my mother okay he's
right enough she cut it off yeah at some
point yeah so thank God it wasn't like
you were like mmm this is weird
no she was like oh bad kids I will go
that long what you know actually four is
the international standard age for
breastfeeding I made so but most people
like oh are you not pleased like their
face is like this is so strange
I believe in breastfeeding well they
well I'm talk about kids like I've got
three of them good
yeah I got two of them and they all look
good they all nursed there you go very
right and it it worked
I believe in it I don't get I did not I
did not breastfeed I was a baby I was a
formula baby
that's why super formula I'm not as
smart as I think I could be I'm not as
dumb as I am feel like you're really
though I'm not that though but I'm as
dumb as I am yeah I'm gonna tell you
that I'm bringing cuz I'm not brilliant
but I'm not a cinnamon Atma no that was
not smart but I'm not as dumb as I as I
am so okay so you you breastfeeding
alongside your younger sister who was
three and a half years younger than you
yeah she still is yeah I know a constant
rate of aging well it depends if one of
you travels in space for an extended
period of time then that starts you know
where they want to go there to space
well yeah we want to go to space but we
don't really want to go to that part of
the conversation okay so take us back to
growing up give us give us paints more
of a picture of glozell growing up first
of all your name you were given the name
glozell which you for saying that we
have unique names but my name is Lincoln
rhett and Link and I've met a number of
rats have you ever met a link I mean
ever Medellin never met a link but you
know of links there's link in a video
game or whatever have you ever do
another glozell or heard of another
glozell no I mean people are naming that
animals that someone just named a dog
there's a fish named after me but of
course next time after you yes to my
fans or enemies depends on if they don't
like them depends on what they do to
their dog yeah exactly exactly but my
father was named özil green and my
mother's named Gloria green so glozell
there you go
people always try to did they give you
that name or did you is this like an
internet name just like my dad was my
Moselle and my mother Gloria I know but
did you put that together
oh my birth certificate says glozell the
neat green yes she wrote it that shooted
the day she was born
I got an ideal ozell and Gloria there
you go that's the only name I've ever
had I didn't need myself that's the only
thing I feel like they really got right
with my name and I I am sorry
everything else my mom has done has been
wrong I'm sorry for asking you that
because I do get offended when people
tell me your real name
yes like no ma'am my name is Lincoln I
it's just short for Lincoln so I got it
tell them that like if you said my name
was Kat and people you and that's not
your real name but that's what you want
to go by then that's what you want to go
by yeah no no what is your real name
that's what I want you to call me
careful shut up okay I understand you
know so I'm sorry no you know in the
street I don't know you know if you get
my apology I don't I'm gonna think about
it I don't think that like I don't I
don't want people interviewing me at
Whole Foods stuff like that people do
that just this week oh sure yeah click
um do you have any kids - no I'm over 40
I don't think I'm have anything about oh
well um have you ever been pregnant
hello yeah yeah somebody oh yeah it's
like I get strange I get strange but you
know people are reflection of yourself
so maybe you know what's the strangest
thing that a fan has ever well you get
like the weird weird scary ones like if
you don't follow me then I'm gonna kill
my dog and they sent a picture like a
knife over get the dog you get and my
dog's name is glozell oh yeah just add
that part to like if you follow me I'll
stop cutting myself like I don't like
that's not joking laughs
so did you block them and then you find
out they killed themselves or what you
just kind of like wow no I think we
haven't gotten that kind of thing how
young is your onions like I have like
right where I'm kind of confused I'm not
sure I know who I am sometimes on
YouTube so I think we've got you gotta
say we've got a young bit more maybe
yeah more guys
yeah probably and they just like oh it's
just 11 you know talk about farts and
this really funny and you know girl's
boobs but I get some wow it's just that
this but I did get some of those this
weekend am I wrong
no okay you're so your sister does she
have an interesting name that's a
different combination of your parents
names uh no yeah in a way just my dad
when she was born the song I'm on my way
to San Jose or something like that by
Dionne Warwick was out so my sister is
named Dion sale after Dionne Warwick who
she's never met and your father your mom
and your dad combine their names for
your name and then it your dad and some
stranger yes okay but cuz Oh Sophia
zoria would have worked think about that
nice yeah I mean it's that it's the
other combination of Gloria in ozo right
Oriya they didn't do that I like that I
should have been you know how many
people have given me like mixtures and
names I never heard that one yeah well
her name is Dion sale so they mean
that's a great name it's actually she
says Dion sale but is Dion sale it's
what the reflection is is she a fan of
Dionne Warwick I don't think anybody's
like an enemy of her but I don't think
she went and got like a album or
anything she I think she had albums but
she was also in the psychic network
hotline psychic friends thing is the
thing that really screwed it up for me
and DL that was what 15 years ago
infomercial
okay so growing up in Florida yes did
that just mean going to a bunch of
amusement parks in heaven there's life I
really enjoy growing up in Orlando
Florida I went to Trinity Lutheran
school from kindergarten eighth grade
and I went to Luther high from ninth to
twelfth grade so I was brought up
Lutheran
there you go
so I was like a private school you
wearing like a uniform we didn't have to
wear uniforms not Catholic come on but
we couldn't wear denim and I couldn't
wear denim denim was like the anti and
and your skirt had to go longer than
your hand your fingertips fingers win
when down by your side
yes you couldn't wear a jean jacket we
can wear denim that way you just
eliminated everything so you couldn't be
that casual that you wearing jeans
that's what it was and we were like we
got spanked also back in when you had
peddling they don't have that now so did
you get paddled or spanked I got spanked
at home yes paddled at school I mean
come on there weren't strange you got
paddled a lot of school not a lot but I
did get paddled or something you got
paddled for forehead not doing my math
homework really well yes this is intense
yes but here's the thing with a paddle
with the board depends on how bad it was
you get one with one hole or two holes
in it in the paddle but more poles the
more I heard yes yes however they didn't
hit you as hard as you got hit so I'm
not gonna do my homework tomorrow we
might as well go ahead hit me again you
told him this no but this is not nothing
I'm gonna chop the tree try to kill me I
think it would be worse because you
couldn't wear denim and that's one of
the thickest materials you want to cover
your end well you're putting it all
together now that's why you couldn't
wear denim because any kids wear denim
we can't faze them with the paddle so
yeah I mean that's the worst you didn't
wear jeans I didn't get my first purging
so I went to college because like if you
couldn't wear at school what was the
point
yeah because there's have been a great
day so I well that's when I found out I
had a lot of junk ajaan that's like what
y'all staring at before oh I'm fine okay
yeah I can't wait to go to college I get
to wear jeans
yes that's what my wild thing was you
know but so okay so what is the school
like I mean you know this is this is a
pretty unique experience I would think a
private lutheran school what you like to
me because I went there from
kindergarten to eighth grade with some
of the same people so I'm the same
people from kindergarten to 12th grade
okay with similar thing for us you know
kindergarten 12th grade British the same
group ourselves yeah so that's not weird
but the Lutheran part well I know denim
part what people have so something some
people have uniforms that means they're
not wearing denim they're not wearing
this then I wearing that so I think it's
weird I wear uniforms I didn't have to
wear uniform so what were your friends
like they were like you know the people
it was a white school is that what
you're saying yes I guess there's some
so but yeah okay I've never had a black
teacher you know and I remember the
first time I'm like I was talking about
Martin Luther to my mom and she said
Martin Luther King and she brought out a
picture I'm like that you know like you
sent me there so hello hello they know
so you knew Martin Luther before you
Martin Luther yes who Martin Luther
senior there's Martin Luther senior
Martin Luther King senior okay Martin
Luther King Jr Martin Luther King's
senior was named after Martin Luther the
monk right so it's all related so I
became a minister so what why did your
parents put you in a private Christian
put me in a private Christian school
because they thought that I would get
beat up at a public school what do you
mean because um I was very awkward and I
know what I don't seem shy but um I'm an
introvert I was just talking about that
today on Facebook I'm an introvert even
though I pretend not to be or somehow it
seems like I'm not well you're an
introvert by definition is your you're
not energized by being around people
being around people as more of a drain
but I could I mean I run I both consider
ourselves in Traverse me where we're
entertainers we like to engage a group
right but we're drained by lots of
conversations with people either loan
time
preach somebody that understand and see
that helps you it's kind of strange
because you end up being with people
like you
you sit in the room and you're just not
talking we're having a great time yeah
let's try that right now just sit and
silence great for a podcast awesome but
I went to the school with the same
people so I wasn't too much of a
introvert so to speak but I was with we
know the same you know your mother and
father of everybody to go to school your
brothers and sister cuz you go for so
long you were comfortable with you yeah
so you you don't realize that you such
an introvert to you go you know 13th the
14th year and at UF and you're just like
hmm I don't know people pears they don't
know me you don't know özil and Gloria
you know this woman
but fortunately or unfortunately I guess
unfortunately unfortunately edit
unfortunately there was a the
Gainesville murderers were going on when
I went to UF so everybody was staying in
so I didn't seem that odd because nobody
was going out cuz people we're getting
really the Gainesville murders College
yes and um yes okay so back before we
get to college I'm still no so okay so
do you think it was a good choice as
scene it seems like the way you talked
about it was a positive experience for
you there think so
because I would I wouldn't be in YouTube
I wouldn't be able to be I get along
with a lot of people and a lot of people
like me act I'm a little more I feel
like I'm diverse you know but if not
then I might be angry at hating white
people and they'll do money they are mad
at Obama you know what I don't feel that
at all well you're just you're saying
that from a young age all the friends
you grew up with they were mostly white
people they were all a hundred percent
white be 100 percent I said yes I was
the only black person in my class and
that was I mean there had to have been
some negatives associated with that I
mean oh you know glozell the one black
girl in our school is that what it was
well yeah but the only there was some
the down part didn't come from the
students it came from their parents
early in the 70s when you okay like here
we go like on Monday and you find out
there was a sleepover and you weren't
invited and the kids were like I wish
you could come well you know mom say you
know we could invite nobody black over
to the house
can that kind of thing now that change
but time
got twelfth grade right in the beginning
early on some of that did happen and
that was issue and how did you deal with
that well I I didn't get upset with the
parents because the kids were so nice I
mean I got along with everybody we were
together I think just it's finite and
plus with that one particular person her
daughter married a black person that I
could have been happier a bit happy I
was just like oh lord have mercy , bite
you bite you bite you do they let him
visit at Christmas or I don't know I
don't care I'm just so happy that was
the funniest thing to me that particular
person so you weren't like mom dad why
you put me in with all these white
people I know I'm the oddball here no I
didn't know I was well the first day of
kindergarten I go in and I'm like Oh
Robby Gifford kind of look like you and
I was like something is wrong with him
his skin Wow but I'm gonna be his friend
because you know when the kids get here
they're gonna pick at him and I'm gonna
I'm gonna stick up for him cuz he's you
know he's cool I was like his eyes are
the wrong color you can almost see
through him they're blue that's that's
gross but you know what I'm gonna be his
friend and obviously he doesn't have a
disease cuz they wouldn't have a mirror
at school and like his hair is yellow
but then as the other kids start coming
in that's when I realized the way y'all
I got a disease oh I better figure out
how to fit in right here and fortunately
people thought I was funny so it sounds
like that your family at least was if
going to school at this school you were
doing black person mmm
no I'm somewhere between I became
African American I don't know what year
that was
but yes I was black man yes I didn't not
know who ever gonna make changes you
changed right before before before I
wouldn't you f
well let's connect the dots as
fulfilling some of those sure some of
those gaps so college you you you end up
doing stand-up comedy because you went
crazy you started wearing denim
yeah started doing Spanish and your
jeans did you sow your Wild Oats
did you never had coffee alcohol but I
grew likes the menses I do like guys
that's that was that that would be my
drug of choice I guess girls cute too
yeah you know what you you were with a
lot of guys in college I was no no no
saying you I don't know what so you
while Oates means exactly
I wasn't sewing I don't know either I
was hoping you could just go with it
well I'm gonna go with it my Wild Oats
happened when I came here so to speak
into California had it Florida become
Los Angeles and you know I moved to
California 2003 and I started one
weekend and I was going to the comedy
club and was teaching was it like okay
if I'm gonna make a go at this I've got
to get to Los Angeles like what was yes
the whole time well back on the care of
a net show there was a Tim Conway show
and on every credit they would say made
in beautiful downtown Burbank or The
Tonight Show made and you know we're in
Burbank I'm like if I just get to
California then Burbank if I could just
get there you know then that's good
that's gonna be able to get to Burbank
yes and then when I went to University
of Florida there mr. Jay Leno said let
the Gator growl which is some kind of
festival thing that we have at UF so I'm
thinking when I tell him how I went to
you up he's gonna be like wolf there you
go like you so totally get tunnel vision
for just yourself that hold on to
something so I'm like I'll just go to
just make sure tell them I what do you
have and I'll probably start working
there at The Tonight Show it's gonna
love that
well it it turn out like that I will end
up going to 200 shows you said 200
I've got went to know I went to over 600
shows over two years yes I've gone yes
in your plan so so what was your be sure
you're going to the to Tim tonight's
show take my show 600 times in two years
yes how do you do this well what
happened was why do you do this so I
said why don't you go to the Tonight
Show maybe you get an idea and so I have
VIP tickets so I didn't have to wait
now we're just going I'm like oh maybe
I'll get some ideas
it was just nice watching the show this
is a classic show that I used to watch I
loved The Tonight Show and when I was
growing up it is not that way now but
when I was growing up with you or comic
and you mean you got all the Tonight
Show whether you got the thumbs up to
come sit down with Johnny Carson or not
don't you yarn are you yawning no I'm
from I'm enthralled if I was I'm so
enthralled that I was just opening my
mouth in all it was not a yawn at all it
was like I wish somebody could see the
cameras my where's the camera he was a
documentary on Johnny Carson recently
and I was fascinated by the fact that
the comics would come out they would do
their stance and they would look over it
Johnny that was their life yeah Johnny
Johnny was gave him the thumbs up it
would change his life how do you how do
you go every day I mean because that
seems like a difficult thing to do
there's people who travel yearly I want
to go to living here and I knew someone
that worked at NBC not at the Tonight
Show and be saying they get on the VIP
list
you just don't know list you show up
because of the show is free to go right
and it's they don't tape at 11:00 they
tape it for so you Donald whatever
you're doing and you can go watch the
show is only is exactly an hour that's
it it didn't take much time out of your
life right okay so and you got the VIP
ticket every day for several months I
had a VIP ticket not realizing that
let's make sure people are like well who
is this we don't know who she is is that
Bill Cosby's granddaughter or something
like you don't know who is able to come
every day you know so someone came up to
me and said why don't you start a blog a
blog I didn't even know what a blog was
I didn't have a computer I don't know so
I went to the library and I started a
blog and I was like oh this is what
happened two bathrooms are dirty here at
The Tonight Show today and blah blah
blah I met this person but I was writing
not knowing that these people were
reading it but what you are we talking
about here 2008 2008 okay and it was a
blog strictly dedicated
it's still up it's called I love Jay
Leno dot-com
it's called glozell glozell of Jay Leno
calm that's what Scott still they're all
the old stuff and they show you pictures
of me in line you know crazy so people
started following this before yes but I
didn't know that people will follow I I
was just writing
my thought so I was like okay cuz I
would write in the diary I would write
every day when I was sitting there so
now now they know what I'm writing cuz
I'm online dummy I'm writing okay I'm
like okay I changed this joke and then
some the joke would change I was like
what's the odds of that and I've done
that what do you mean the joke would
change cuz he between taping today
no no because he would do the same joke
more than once he doesn't do brand-new
jokes all the time every night he might
do a joke on Monday and turnaround if
it's still hot about I said Paris Hilton
or somebody I'm worried a little bit but
he'll still talk about hair he'll do
sometimes is the same joke it was high
it'll be hot again not everybody catches
everything I watch it every night really
right you should know I mean I know is
it links not watching you but you went
to six shows like that is documented I
was in the paper and it was getting a
lot of my record first of all okay so
you've got the blog going people are
interested in race right yeah and and
then people visiting notes are changing
as a result of your blog two or three
times what happened was the strike which
everybody from the inside was outside
this was like my dream come true
everybody from every show was out there
striking I'm taking pictures with him
but I knew that they were gonna go back
and when they went back they were
looking at the blog you know I'm taking
pictures of what's going on they went
back to a job I was just going back to
the Tonight Show but you started making
videos I start making videos of the
people in line interviewing like hey I'm
thought I thought that the interest was
the people in line not thinking that
people thought that I was funny
interviewing people in line mmm-hmm you
know so I'm like okay so you mean people
from Australia and Japan in this place
in that place and because of my
background I guess you know I could talk
to you about anything like but you
weren't harassing anybody right I wasn't
arresting anybody but I also was writing
everything about good bad and ugly about
The Tonight Show about everything from
the from the bathrooms to who got kicked
out and what really happened what didn't
air too much information
they were eligible with the amount of
disclosure they never said but now
they're saying this is what I was
writing maybe they were seeing it kind
of like stalker territory that well what
happened was they asked me to come to
the green room which I thought this is
my moment
two years and they're like you can't
come here anymore and I thought I was
where I was thought I was gonna be
punched I'm waiting for Jay to come out
like what like what I'm bad one or two
women me and Joan Rivers are banned from
the Tonight Show
I kind of feel honored but you know then
and I it was it was the greatest thing
ever because right then my world was it
was done my world was completely The
Tonight Show if people want to talk to
me they would come to the Tonight Show
and like okay cuz they know that I was
going to be there people from my church
will hold my spot in line if I had to go
do something because that's that was my
thing that was the only thing I had so
there you go
so and once again who comes to tonight's
show white people I didn't realize how
easy it was the spot that I was coming
every day because the only thing black
about The Tonight Show was ban right
that was the I mean the audience is not
black oh not even when Obama came it was
and you people had work how did you feel
when you were you were shut out first I
really tried to hate Jay even though you
know what if I had never been there
never met him never he never said that
thing at when I you know when I was at
you have let the Gator growl and it's
not his fault even though I do believe
that he was the one that's like okay
this is enough you know I believe it's
him but it was a good thing and I loved
him and I was it a good thing it was a
good thing because the guy from The
Tonight The Today Show Lenny I guess
this is a black thing we just stand out
and watch white people shows anyway he
was there for over 20 years that
could've easily been me easily I could
have easily only talked about people
that came to the next show and not done
the cinnamon challenge and not do the
other things because I thought what was
important what people were watching was
people that were going to Jay Leno
because I thought the Tonight Show was
so huge and now it was about you know it
really came by you now I do but
happening when do you understand that
after I started doing videos like oh
maybe I can watch the show start talking
about I'm still trying to connect to the
show somehow cuz like who cared about me
who was I I thought I was the Tim you
know just that was it and since then
they started their own blog which is
great and moving on but how did so how
did it shift from you were just watching
the show and continuing to blog too I'm
like well I'll watch the show but then I
was like that's crazy I mean so I it
took a while for me to figure out what
am I going to do I don't know what I'm
gonna do I've been doing this for two
years and there's been great this is my
cheers people wrote to me like can you
pick me up a ticket I'm coming in but I
didn't get chance to give it to sure I'm
gonna go to the office and pick up
tickets all the time this I love doing
that I have a problem and I'm looking
looking for it to meeting the people
there's people that I met in that line
that I'm still friends with now really
mm-hmm
so what was the first thing you did post
Jay Leno that's when my first viral hit
came was my push-up bra help me get my
man back driving in the car
mm-hmm what was the thought process it's
like we're gonna do a ghetto soap opera
and I my name will be Tracy and this guy
his name would be Peter and I was on my
way to meet Peter at the park however a
accident just happened so I was like oh
I need to record this foot please
nobody's here yeah so I'm like okay
hello I'm gonna corner Okavango I like a
shell this is and then I look in the
mirror and I had on my little red hair
my tricep you could tell the de voice
change if you watch it from beginning
cuz I'm like I was really concerned
they're like let's let's try play and
then I'm trying to tell Oh smoking and
give me see that you you see the car
burned burned up car it was really
happening Cahuenga right did you're
telling the address of the actor I'm
trying to I'm trying to say in the world
I'm trying to help somebody and then you
decided to go into character what cuz I
see that it wasn't glozell I'm like well
that's you know so then I was like yeah
that's tri-c and then almost hit a car
no I stay on your side but I almost hit
him I'm taping trying to
what a cool a hair done and these people
like burning up like literally these
like yeah you totally forget about them
you never hear from them in the video
once you go into Carrick and will you
say viral video I mean we're talking
this 20 million here 20 million guys
that was viral diem it's not viral now
no no it is our views I hope it's to
know you looking at like my friend
Rebecca black when she's got over like
220 million is incredible and I think
that I'm fascinated by the fact that how
many people who have watched that video
and shared it knew that you were playing
a character them know nobody nobody and
I was like these people are crazy
like you should so get out whatever Mike
first of all I was surprised that people
didn't know you can dye your hair with
kool-aid cuz black people do you can dye
your hair cool a and for that's so funny
like okay that's one of the things that
like I can bring the cultures together
you know like right so you knew that you
just understood based on the internet
and YouTube at the time that most of the
people who are watching or probably
white people who are commenting on doing
I'm like no it really was ahead then I
go forget it it kept on 1 million 2
million 3 million there was no way to
try to keep up with trying to explain if
you go to the first comment you'll see
like a first couple of hundred I was
trying to like no really this really was
happening and I'm glozell and nothing
forget it but when did it hit you that
okay
alright this YouTube thing is getting
this distraction I'm getting millions of
views I'm gonna keep feeding this thing
I'm gonna keep going back and trying to
make this happen over and over again uh
when I think the first big thing was
Perez Hilton because I heard of a
mouthing like wow that's big and he was
like it when it comes to blogging and
vlogging at the time and there's an in
I've read somewhere that was at Elijah
Wood mentioned you on the Jimmy Kimmel
yes yes what video was he referencing
and with how did that go down
all right we were in the middle of
nowhere in the middle of nowhere and I'm
obsessed with the show called Wolf Ridge
right okay yeah yeah okay so we're in
the middle of nowhere we go to this one
Quiznos there is nothing but about two
or three hours before and that nothing
like two hours after us going to the
Quiznos and then I was talking to I
watch Wilfred the night before okay I'm
really big on shows when I love a show a
live show I had to go to the bathroom
meanwhile I'm I can't stand going to
poll the bathrooms most people have
never even known me to go to a public
bath I put like 18,000 tissues all over
that toilet okay because I I can't squat
that long you know same so I put all the
paper towels okay
and then I stuff and then I tried to
flush them but they wouldn't go down and
I was like well I walk out who is there
Elijah I was like no what Elijah world
is in the Quiznos in the quiz no see he
ordered a vegetarian just so you know um
of course so and I know that he's gonna
have to use the bathroom because there's
nothing before you get to the end
there's nothing after what this town is
this this was on the way we went to
Oakland so on the way back
once that unlike the after five or
something I mean off the in the bony
okay this was like a crazy thing say
don't know he's I know he's gonna have
to go to the barely he knows that I just
came out but he knows all he see is the
brown paper just stuff to me and I was
just like man take a picture with him
and then I left I did a video about
Elijah I just want you to know that it
was nothing L it was just number one in
the bathroom but what happened was that
and I you know I just did a video and
you came clean that came directly to
Elijah you know cuz I'm so sorry I
really love will and I did say that I
loved you in Lord of the Flies even
though I like cuz I don't watch movies
right so I didn't I told her Jack that
up you know I don't know them from any
whatever whatever movies are there
because I don't care about the movies I
saw wolf it you know people don't come
up
oh that dog show no that's what I like
oh yeah sorry
so I'm like I'm Lord and flies blah blah
and I'm looking at the Lord of the Flies
exactly yeah so when he went and you
didn't know he saw it until he was on
cam oh no and people like he talked
about him at all
but he didn't talk about the bathroom
which I was I was thankful because and
he tweeted me he goes I did use a
plunger glows I was like oh right
he's yawning again can we stop now
you're that's a false accusation I was
[Laughter]
an air biscuit on air biscuits now what
about finding your husband I was at a
festival in the Orlando area and my mom
was folks to go and pass out flyers for
our you know okay just check pass out
flyers for congresswoman Corrine brown
and I come in town and I'm like mom I
don't really want to go to the festival
and she's like I need to go to my prayer
meeting which means she was playing
cards okay they don't even pray over
cards so I was like okay so I go there
for my mom and I passing out the Flyers
is hi it was outside I'm like oh I get
up it's packed I get up from my seat I
come back this guy's in the seat and how
he was dressed I figured well he
definitely don't have a woman and I was
like oh he's kind of cute for a black
guy you know cuz I'm one of you right
that's why we talk he's kept like I and
um so we're talking and talking that's
all gonna talking and um there you go to
two months later you moved to California
I go I'm not I'm not moving back here so
right you know see you two months of
just like talking on the phone ya know I
came back to floor my all my family's in
Florida so I would say
and then I'm like well I'm not moving
here so I don't know what this really is
gonna be nothing but so in the Wild Oats
there we go and that's it you mad at me
because how you find a black man no
we're not I went there with them you got
to go to Orlando so okay so it's two
months of long-distance dating anyhow
when did he move out here how long ago
was that before engagement um we've
known each other five years so he moved
out oh so you were dating for five years
after he moved out to LA mmm yeah so he
moved and I asked them to manage me
because I'm like I don't drive like I'm
crazy person you know if you could just
you know emails come in and out of that
do what people don't you know your phone
you were like help me with my business
yeah I'll help you dress he's 10 years
older than me so I mean from the
military so he's very okay you know now
he's a little you loose relax you got it
denim yes yes yes you too two months
into your marriage yes uh-huh
and how's that going married to your
manager now got married to my manager
all right last question hmm is you okay
yes I you like you cuz you want to know
Oh what happened was I used to say hello
this is glozell everyone doing alright
when I do stand-up and then I'll say hey
how you doing cuz I love friends right
but there's someone else named Wendy
Williams that goes through the wood it
feels like Oh Wendy Williams I was like
oh I have to change this cuz I don't
want them to think that I was copying
her mm-hmm when I was copying friends
anyway so I was like so it is you all
right this is you okay
and then people like is you okay they
kept that that was all the comments I no
one said anything about the video so I
just kept that there's one video west's
is you alright and the next one became
is you okay a night and they latched on
to it that was it it was one of those
everything that is good for me has been
a mistake everything so people like I
don't
know what I'm doing and I think that's
helped me because everybody else like
we've got this kind of camera and we use
this kind of this and we edit out there
and there and I'm like oh how many
subscribers I don't know after I don't
know what two million have I don't add
it's quite I don't know how to ask one
I've actually beat up a computer cuz I
don't know how to use it I couldn't get
a Lady Gaga video to play and I was just
like you know what I hate this computer
and then she tweeted me so it was worth
it well it just seems to me like things
are going pretty okay maybe better than
okay for you well I'm here I'm like what
and I don't know what it's worth but we
we do think that you are more than okay
thanks for coming in here you need to
sign the table alright sure wrong pin
see I get it wrong why ya to say that
slightly
I don't even this is a dry erase marker
and you need a dream pen oh wow you just
went for it
[Music]
that was our conversation with glozell
green what a sweet person she's very
sweet very funny I am though you know a
little uncomfortable with the fact that
she kept accusing me of yawning well
yeah I would look over at you and you
would it looked like you were yawning
what are you I gone legitimately one
time and that was the time she caught me
and it was and I was thinking what
happened I'm gonna conceal this a little
bit it's just because I got it really
earlier the other day and I'm not really
gay I haven't gotten caught up on my
sleep we I mean moving about to tune out
or anything I mean I was totally engaged
in the conversation and then after that
every time I looked at her the only
thing I was thinking was I got a I do I
can't look like I'm gonna yawn yeah I
gotta admit I did y'all twice completely
through my nose after that I just opened
my mouth getting ready to say something
one time and she called me out on it but
I know I deserve it
and if you if you pull that again this
is gonna be so low I'm gonna have to go
solo can you yawn through completely
through your nose I've learned how to
did that a long time ago why didn't you
do it tonight
I did every other what I'm telling you
is that the only other time she accused
me of it was I wasn't yawning I did yawn
twice as she didn't
catch me and it wasn't because I wasn't
engaged just because I'm at I'm tired
right now
I'm a hard-working man can you yawn
that's no no don't dodge the issue here
you're dodging in question can you yawn
completely through your nose
I don't think so Rhett a lot of people
don't realize that it's totally possible
do you need to apologize to doors l do
right now I mean do you need to tweet an
apology tour
I just yawned come directly 100% through
my nose direct message it and I can
apologize for something that was
extremely rude it isn't true I know you
did you just said you did it three times
I did it once it's not profession call
me the standard here on ear biscuits is
high and you were you and you can't even
see it just my clothes l that was
awesome she's awesome she's got a whole
lot of views she's got a festival she's
doing a festival oh yeah check out our
channel youtube.com slash glozell one
that's closed l green let her know that
we sent you and we're gonna be doing
this next week people in the next I know
the pattern I'm every way to be sleeping
eight hours a day for our next guests I
will not be yawning at all I won't even
be yawning through my nose there will be
absolutely no indication that I am
anywhere near tired in fact I'm going to
sleep through the day before we do this
next time okay I will be totally rested
and hope your ears will be ready to
receive a biscuit all right you'll hear
from us next week and Rhett why don't
you teach me how to yondu my nose okay
you
[Music]
[Music]